chérie je voulais donner tout de suite
géraldine will et maxime
on est là à douze années de plus en plus
droit alors vous commencez géraldine et
maxime alors de 1 2 3 et vous voulez
vous passer lost d'accord poêlée de
banos à la halle et honteux passant dans
deux en deux ans 2003 vous êtes en 3
attention julien kelly julien combes et
kelly silence qui attrapent donc vous
tourner allez assez bon 2 c'est bon
attention vous mordez tension monte de
loi voilà crois c'est moi
jean jouzel battu boxing et notamment au
km5 son panier
sa 9 dur ce propos si la connerie c'est
jade et vous m avec maxime merci
attention isabelle et mathieu famille
avec des amis je vous rappelle tpn fait
jeu pour jouer avec tous les chéris vous
désignez un ventirad celui que vous avez
envie qu'il gagne je jouerai avec
benjamin biolay a mis pas mal aimé ça
mais recule à chaque fois en cloche vous
avec la tullow 4 attention les chéris
par janvier et bouder le coureur wallon
vous avec vous gagnez des jeux pendant
toute l'année j'ai amorti up oil et
aucune offre et gageons qu'à six femmes
permettait aux petites minutes vous
formez je trouve une pierre vanek a
aucune honte alors que le tour soit m
merci à l'aller dalton smith des forces
et une section un effort en génuflexion
euros
[Applaudissements]
des gens me disent merci on a maintenant
valérie et julie ont formé sera couverte
à la rampe ouverte derrière c'est
quelque chose tu as maté manche ultime
en mai recul de l'euro ça c'est bien oh
là là et bien la marquise ça va bien la
lgv orthez oui la marquise cet achat est
votre rôle
cette légalité non ils sont huit
égalités sa joie sur un dernier run vous
plaît qui a dit que c'est un oeuf dur
moi mais moi non non ça travaille dur et
je vous prouverez tout beau le progrès
mais dès qu'ils ont un toit de jamin
métaphore bela lugosi envie de finir ma
vie j'ai zéro envers froid qui les
guideront j'ai ouvert td vers le haut
regarde comme attend ça va tu as quitté
holla holla sa tante comme toi asie mon
coeur mais pense à ta femme way back
elle annonça t femmes
allez hop la série n'est pas si dur à
8,26 crawshaw vase est serré était la
plus belle couche alors oui c'est la 3
égalités
c'est ça qu'a dit julia et gilles venez
me rejoindre et -6 serviette à on dirait
qu'on fait ça toute la journée avec une
serviette quoi tout ça ça nous est tous
à 7 face à cette foule et audace est
allé au bec jean-michel pas alors
comment ce premier qui arrive à 8
bon c'est pas toi exactement ce retard
il va bien et cali et julien ces partis
jour 1.4 votre poids en off à gagner
pendant toute la nuit ou peut-être bien
en cloche
ouais en cloche 20 attention aux murs là
où j'ai continué parce que si allah vers
le haut
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ils ont réussi à vue technique allez
attention c'est parti
concentre toi j -louis la marquise est
magnifique
sa soeur la toya voilà qui va se taper
jugnot sincères 9g parole à la radio
faire alalalala enfin bravo à vous
contenter du bronze bisous bisous fait
chaud la pousse bisous il va du l'autre
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]